>> Laura: IT'S TIME NOW FOR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN," WHERE HE
EXPOSED THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
TONIGHT WE BREAK DOWN THE OPTICS
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP VERSUS CHUCK
AND NANCY.
THE REBUTTAL THAT LAUNCHED 1,000
MEMES.
WE DO THAT WITH OUR OWN RAYMOND
ARROYO WHO WAS CAUGHT ON FILM
COMMITTING A CRIME?
NO WAY.
WE HAVE SURVEILLANCE VIDEO.
JOINING US NOW, THE
AFOREMENTIONED RAYMOND ARROYO.
THIS THING LAST NIGHT, WE WERE
ALL SITTING BACK THERE IN THE
OFFICES AND WHEN THEY WALKED
OUT, CHUCK AND NANCY, AFTER THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE, THE PEALS OF
LAUGHTER.
NOW, THAT'S UNFAIR.
TV, NOT EVERYBODY'S A
SUPERMODEL.
THAT'S FINE.
WHY WAS THAT SO COMPELLING?
STICK IT WAS SO COMPELLING BECAU
STICK IT WAS SO COMPELLING BECAE
AUDIENCES WATCH.
IT HAD A LOT TO DO WITH THE
STAGING.
IT HAD A LOT TO DO WITH WHAT THE
SPEAKERS, WHAT PELOSI, THE
PRESIDENT, AND SCHUMER WERE
DOING INTENTIONALLY OR
UNINTENTIONALLY, LAURA.
ON TV, LITTLE THINGS MATTER.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR VISUAL
CLUES TO AGREE OR DISAGREE WITH
WHAT IS BEING SPEAKERS SAME.
IN THIS CASE, IN THE CASE OF THE
REBUTTAL, THINGS GOT A LITTLE
CREEPY RIGHT OFF THE TOP.
FROM THE WIDE SHOT, THE SLOW
PUSH.
>> SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT ABOUT
HOW WE CAN END THIS SHUTDOWN AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> NOTICE HOW SCHUMER IS STARING
INTO THE CAMERA WITH THIS
MENACE.
NANCY NEVER BLINKS, AS SHE
SPEAKS.
SHE IS KIND OF JUST ROBOTICALLY
RUNNING THROUGH IT.
THE HALLWAY PUSH AT THE TOP,
THERE WAS A BIG MISTAKE, LAURA.
>> Laura: WHO IS PRODUCING?
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA DID HIS BIG
FIRST MEET AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION?
THEY FLY IN SPIELBERG TO PRODUCE
IT?
IT WAS SHOT WELL.
THIS WAS LIKE, THIS WAS LIKE THE
KIDS AT HOFSTRA.
>> THIS REMINDED ME OF A HORROR
MOVIE WITH THE SLOW PUSH
WATCHING THESE TWO FIGURES.
>> Laura: PSYCHO.
>> HELLO.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
THAT'S AWFUL.
>> THIS IS A MOVIE CALLED "IT
FOLLOWS."
THEN THERE WAS A MOMENT WHERE
PELOSI FINISHED HER PORTION OF
THE SPEECH AND THEN SHE HANDED
THE BATON TO SCHUMER.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE.
TELLS US A LOT.
>> THE GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU.
LEADER SCHUMER.
>> LOOK WHAT SHE DOES WITH HER
JOB.
SHE DOES THIS STRANGE JAW
READJUSTMENT.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
>> AUDIENCE WERE WONDERING WHY
MY THROWN OFF BY THIS?
THOSE VISUALS HAD DIFFERENT
CUES.
THEY MAKE PEOPLE A LITTLE
FRIGHTENED.
AND THEN SCHUMER, HE SPEAKS TO
HER, THINKS HER WITHOUT EVER
LOOKING OVER TO HER.
"THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SPEAKER
PELOSI.
LET ME TELL YOU THE BORDERS IN
IN BIG TROUBLE."
>> Laura: DON'T DO THAT AGAIN.
>> IT HAD THE AIR OF NOSFERATU.
>> Laura: OH, MY.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Laura: REALLY SCRAPING THE
BOTTOM OF THE BARREL.
>> STARING IN THAT WAY.
THAT'S WHAT IT REMINDED ME OF.
>> Laura: I KEPT ITCHING AT
THIS.
WHAT DID HE LOOK LIKE?
IT WAS LIKE THAT ONE VILLAIN.
>> TO FACE FROM BATMAN.
WE'VE GOT TO GO.
WERE GOING TO RUN OUT OF TIME.
LET'S GO TO THE PRESIDENT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
YOU AND I SAW SOMETHING WHEN WE
WATCH THIS.
THE PRESIDENT IT WAS IN COMMAND.
HE WAS SEATED THERE.
IF YOU NOTICE, WATCH THE
PRESIDENT.
HIS EYES ARE A LITTLE OFF
CAMERA.
>> Laura: HOW DOES THAT
HAPPEN?
STICK OUT EITHER THE PROMPTER IS
BENEATH THE LENS WHICH MEANS YOU
BENEATH THE LENS WHICH MEANS YOR
BENEATH THE LENS WHICH MEANS YOE
LOOKING DOWN RATHER THAN INTO
THE CAMERA OR SOMETHING WAS OFF,
THE CAMERA WAS TOO CLOSE TO HIM.
BUT WHATEVER, HE'S NOT LOOKING
THROUGH TO THE VIEWER.
THAT'S THE ONE --
>> Laura: HE WAS --
>> OTHERWISE HE WAS REALLY IN
COMMAND, VERY EMOTIVE.
>> Laura: HE WAS KIND OF
REAGAN-ASKED WHAT HE WAS A
LITTLE OFF ON THE CAMERA SHOT
BUT I SHOULDN'T SAY THAT BECAUSE
WHOEVER DID THAT IS NOW GOING TO
GET IN TROUBLE.
PROBABLY ONLY WE NOTICE IT
BECAUSE WE ARE TEA PEOPLE.
PICKY, PICKY.
>> CHUCK AND NANCY CAPTURED THE
IMAGINATION OF MANY ON THE
INTERNET, SCHOOL OF MEMES ROSE
UP ALMOST INSTANTLY.
HERE ARE THREE OF MY FAVORITES.
THIS ONE IS THE GREENACRES MEME.
>> MEXICO TO PAY FOR THIS
INEFFECTIVE --
UNABLE TO CONVINCE --
♪ ♪
>> IT IS THE GREENACRES THEME.
THE NEXT MEME, I CALL IT THE
HEAD SWAP.
THIS KEEPS ME UP AT NIGHT.
>> Laura: NO, NO, NO.
>> THEY PUT PELOSI'S FACE ON ONE
SIDE AND SCHUMER'S ON THE OTHER
AND FINALLY NANCY JUG OF SUPER
VILLAINS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
OBAMA SAYING THAT WE NEED FRESH
BLOOD IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND I KEPT SEEING THAT GOING
OKAY.
YOU ARE AT THE OFF THE RECORD
LUNCHEON.
YOU ARE WITH ALL THE FANCY
PEOPLE.
>> THEY INVITED ANCHORS OF
DIFFERENT NETWORKS BUT SOMEONE
CLEARLY BROKE THE GROUND RULES
HERE.
THAT HURTS EVERYBODY BECAUSE NOW
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET ANY
INSIGHT INTO WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD TWO
PEOPLE BRIEFED ON THE DISCUSSION
SHARED THIS INFORMATION WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, ONE
OF THESE ANCHORS TALK TO THEIR
STAFF AND THEY LINKED IT.
>> Laura: IT WERE GOING TO
NEED TO STOP BECAUSE WE HAVE
SOME BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
AFTER A FRANTIC MANHUNT, POLICE
ARE MAKING AN ARREST THE MAN
ACCUSED OF RELIEVING HIMSELF IN
A CALIFORNIA FAMILIES YARD AND
STEALING EXTENSION CORDS.
[LAUGHS]
THE SUSPECT ALSO CAUGHT ON
CAMERA GETTING INTIMATE
WITH AN INTERCOM.
THAT WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AT SOMEONE ELSE'S HOME.
RAYMOND, WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY?
ARE YOU THE DOORBELL LIQUOR?
>> THE MAN WAS IDENTIFIED AS
ROBERTO DANIEL ARROYO, NO
RELATION, THANK GOD.
THIS POOR GUY IS A HOMELESS MAN.
HE'S LICKING -- HE'S LICKING THE
DOORBELL OF THIS HOME.
HE BARELY DID THIS FOR THREE
HOURS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, LAURA,
BUT I'VE NEVER LOOKED ANYTHING
FOR THREE HOURS AND IF I DO, AT
THE RISK OF SOUNDING LIKE ONE OF
THOSE COMMERCIALS, CALL MEDICAL
HELP.
OTHER THAN STAMPS, I'M NOT GOING
TO BE LICKING ANYTHING FOR MORE
THAN 3 MINUTES MUCH LESS THREE
HOURS.
IT WAS NOT ME.
I WAS NOT DOING IT.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
WAIT A SECOND.
THE VEHICLE GO TO A FEDERAL
JUDGE IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT AND
HE COULD SAY IT WAS AN